half a million refugees and water on
countries have now crossed the
Mediterranean to Greece alone EU leaders
have shown unity but they can't find
agreement a plan to resettle and
relocate 160 thousand refugees is yet to
be fully implemented over 5500 European
filmmakers including Juliette Binoche
Daniel Craig and valeria bruni tedeschi
have signed a petition calling on the
Eid act collectively the premiere highly
appropriate she knows Italian merge
saamne girl lamaze majority dijon jean
de jong ban volante middle from passive
well a que fue do require delivery don't
need the CD they massage the position so
okay little bonbon TP so I crochet the
director of the oscar-winning film the
artist was one of a group of the
signatories present at the Parliament
some at the meeting question the
involvement of the elite of world cinema
but to others they're voice was an
important one the European Union is not
just a union of economics and the market
is a it's a union of culture but even
more important it's a union of images
much of what happens with refugees is in
response to the images that we see and
it's absolutely right that filmmakers
and actors and artists are involved in
this time then to break the silence for
those most in need
Oh